David Blaine's plan was to spend forty
four days in a see-through plexiglass
box dangling from a crane near London
Bridge subsisting on nothing but water
he called the Endeavour above the below
which some observers considered a bit
much the British were not impressed they
were not impressed when blaine
pronounces venture the most extreme
exercise in isolation and physical
deprivation ever attempted or when he
said I'm a great artist nothing more
nothing less they were not impressed by
the multi-million pound deal he struck
with Sky Television and they were not
impressed that he had decided to confine
himself to a glass prison and
voluntarily starve when so many people
were actually incarcerated in real
prisons and actually starving the Mayor
of London said it was disrespectful to
the IRA members who died on hunger
strikes in the 1980s blame duly took his
place in his box but the stunt totally
backfired was as if he were award the
18th century and Blaine was in the
stocks crowns of cynical lunders
gathered underneath his box and laughed
at him they pelted him with bananas
french fries and eggs they made such a
mess at his girlfriend the unusually
named German model minun van gherkin had
to be cranked up on a crane to wash the
food to try this off the box with a
cloth we never had anything like this in
New York she said Blaine's helpers
raised the box so it would not be with
an egg throwing distance a group of men
positioned themselves on Tower Bridge
and tried to hit it with golf balls a
hamburger van pulled up below and began
ostentatiously frying onions and other
foods his enticing aroma was designed to
upset Blaine starving as he was a man
tried to cut off his water supply some
youths frightened him by shining laser
bends into his eyes a homeless person
sat nearby behind a sign saying please
give generously I am attempting 44 days
on continuous alcohol abuse women took
off their tops and flashed their breasts
at Blaine men pull down their pants and
mooned him people stayed up all night
playing the drums so as to disturb the
tranquility of anyone who might be
trying to sleep in an overhead box
a radio station urges listen Ursa stand
in the cold chanting ding ding ding in
an obnoxious fashion someone blasted
this long living in a box by the British
pop funk group living in a box a
remote-control helicopter buzzed by
dangling a juicy looking cheeseburger on
a string there was unpleasant
speculation of a plane's bathroom
arrangements in keeping with Britain's
well-known lavatory alip sessions
Blaine's explanation of his plans for
his liquid waste that it would be
expelled via to bleeding out of the box
had left a solid waste situation
deliberately vague adult diapers were
mentioned a radio host took to calling
Blaine nappy man newspaper columnist
speculated that the illusionists had
been eating on the sly saying that he
actually looked kind of fat considering
in the Sun Jane Moore referred to him as
that total twerp currently dangly in a
glass box above the Thames in the
guardian Catherine Bennett said that the
satirical response to Blaine illustrated
the temperamental gulf between Britain
and America because Britons know how to
tell the difference between a huckster
and a hero she urged Londoners to engage
in a mass public ridicule by taunting
Blaine with food even a blob of oily ice
cream taste exquisite when consumed in
the suspended company of the
preposterous posed starving blame she
said true he did have a supporters
including American tourists regular
visitors who believed they had
telepathic communication with him and
that he was sending them special signals
from the box people who felt sorry for
him and the paranormalists uri geller
who announced he is the quality of
Rasputin when blaine finally came down
thin and weak and with his major organs
on the verge of collapse or so he said
the general feeling was that above the
below had been beyond the absurd a huge
pretentious failure but what was it that
made ordinary Britons teased and resent
him so much because he was making such a
big deal about it because he had
revealed himself to be a puffed-up
self-promoter rather than the friendly
kind of eccentric who does what he does
for himself rather than for public
acclaim he was capable of going to the
pub and laughing in himself over a few
pints because he did not know when
enough is enough
you